[HOST]: Hey, Mira, I came across something really fascinating recently. It's about those A I leaderboards, you know, where companies show off their scores when they release new models. I noticed a pattern， a couple of years ago, everyone was obsessed with a test called MMLU, but now, it seems like nobody even mentions it anymore. It's like it just vanished from the conversation.
[MIRA]: Yes, your observation is remarkably accurate. The MMLU test, indeed, two years ago, was a battleground, a highly contested domain where every A I lab aimed to demonstrate superiority. Now, if you examine the technical reports from these same companies, it's typically just a passing mention, almost an afterthought. It's as if there's an unspoken, collective agreement that the scores from this particular benchmark have simply ceased to be relevant, no longer serving as a true differentiator.
[HOST]: My initial thought was that the test must be outdated, or the questions were obsolete, something along those lines. I figured maybe the A I models had just moved so far beyond its scope that it no longer posed a challenge. But then I went and did some digging, and I found out that wasn't the case at all. The questions haven't been changed. Not a single one. It's the exact same set of problems from when it was first introduced. That's what really got me thinking.
[MIRA]: Precisely. And that, in my view, is precisely what makes this phenomenon worthy of a deep dive, perhaps even an entire article. The questions are unchanged, the scoring criteria remain identical, fundamentally, nothing about the test itself has shifted. Yet, its significance, its utility as a meaningful metric, has quietly, almost imperceptibly, evaporated. You could argue it's obsolete, and in a practical sense, it certainly is. But if you were to ask someone to pinpoint specific design flaws or inherent weaknesses in the test itself, it becomes surprisingly difficult to articulate. It's a paradox.
[HOST]: Wait, this is truly peculiar. A test where the questions haven't changed, the standards haven't changed, but it just。 stopped working? It's no longer effective? What on earth happened here? This isn't just about a specific benchmark， it feels like there's a deeper principle at play. What's the underlying mechanism behind this kind of obsolescence?
[MIRA]: Yes, that is the core question I aimed to excavate in my analysis. To put it simply， the more useful a test becomes, the more intensely it will be targeted for optimization. And the more aggressively it is optimized, the more rapidly that test loses its original meaning and purpose. Its very utility, its perceived value, ultimately becomes its undoing. Usefulness itself, in this context, is a curse.
[HOST]: Whoa, usefulness itself is a curse. That sounds incredibly counter-intuitive, almost like a philosophical riddle. Are you saying that precisely because everyone took it seriously, precisely because it was so highly regarded and focused on, it stopped being effective? That's quite a twist. It's like the more you try to hit a target, the more it moves away, or perhaps, the more you hit it, the less meaningful the act of hitting it becomes.
[MIRA]: That is precisely the essence of it. And this isn't an isolated issue with MMLU alone. This is a structural predicament that, I argue, all A I benchmarks are inherently susceptible to. I refer to it as the half-life of benchmarks, drawing a parallel to radioactive elements. Any fixed, standardized test, from the moment it is adopted and becomes a target, immediately begins to decay in its ability to accurately measure what it initially set out to evaluate. Its validity has a finite lifespan, and that lifespan is accelerating.
[HOST]: Okay, that's a fascinating and somewhat unsettling concept. So, let's really delve into this today. Let's start with MMLU. Many listeners might not be familiar with it, so could you please first explain exactly what MMLU is, what it stands for, and what its original purpose was? Give us the full picture.
[MIRA]: Certainly. MMLU stands for Massive Multi-task Language Understanding. While the full name provides some context, the core idea is more important. You can envision it as an extraordinarily comprehensive, perhaps even intimidating, university-level examination. It spans an astonishing fifty-seven distinct academic disciplines, ranging from highly abstract subjects like abstract algebra and theoretical physics, to practical fields like clinical medicine, all the way to nuanced areas such as moral philosophy and even U.S. history. In total, it comprises nearly sixteen thousand multiple-choice questions. The fundamental premise behind its design was this， if an A I system could accurately answer questions across such an incredibly diverse array of domains, it would strongly suggest that the A I possessed genuine erudition, a broad and deep understanding, and perhaps even a rudimentary form of reasoning capability. It was intended to be a robust measure of general intelligence, not just rote memorization or pattern matching in a narrow field.
[HOST]: Oh, so it's like giving an A I a complete set of undergraduate final exams, and not just one or two subjects, but all of them simultaneously. A true academic gauntlet, designed to test the breadth and depth of its learned knowledge across the entire human intellectual spectrum. That sounds incredibly challenging, even for a human.
[MIRA]: Yes, that analogy is quite apt. It was conceived as a formidable challenge. When MMLU was first introduced in 2020, for instance, GPT-3, which was then considered a cutting-edge model, achieved a score of approximately forty-four percent on this test. The designers, at that time, were quite confident, even publicly stating their belief that the test would remain a significant and enduring challenge for A I systems for the foreseeable future, certainly for several years to come. They genuinely thought they had created a durable benchmark.
[HOST]: Forty-four percent? That's less than half! So it wasn't even close to mastering it back then. That really underscores the difficulty you mentioned. What happened after that? How did models progress from such a relatively low baseline?
[MIRA]: Four years later, the top-performing models are now consistently scoring in excess of ninety percent. Some are even pushing towards ninety-five percent or higher, depending on the specific model and evaluation setup.
[HOST]: From forty-four percent to over ninety percent in just four years? That pace of improvement is absolutely staggering. It's an exponential leap, far exceeding what most might have predicted. It’s not just progress， it’s a revolution in performance. How did that happen so quickly?
[MIRA]: Indeed, the speed of improvement has been so rapid that it undoubtedly surprised even the original designers. And critically, once models began to consistently achieve these high scores, the MMLU score transitioned into little more than a perfunctory detail, a mere formality. Companies would briefly mention their MMLU results in their technical reports, perhaps a single sentence noting their score, before swiftly moving on to discuss other, newer benchmarks，tests that still retained some genuine discriminatory power and truly differentiated between leading models. The MMLU score became a checkbox, not a highlight.
[HOST]: So, it essentially got retired from active duty as a meaningful benchmark. It's like a grand champion that's been defeated so many times, it's no longer considered a challenge. But you said earlier that the questions themselves haven't changed. If the test material is identical, where exactly did the problem lie? Was it just that the A I models got inherently smarter, or was there something else at play that led to its obsolescence?
[MIRA]: The fundamental issue lies in the sheer intensity and focus of the optimization efforts. Consider this， when an entire industry，hundreds of companies, thousands of research teams, vast pools of computational resources，all converge on MMLU scores as the primary target to conquer, the impact is immense. Larger models, exponentially more computing power, increasingly sophisticated and finely tuned training methodologies, all of these formidable resources are unilaterally directed at this singular objective. It becomes an all-out assault on the benchmark.
[HOST]: It sounds like a military campaign, or perhaps a massive, coordinated effort where literally thousands of armies are all marching towards the exact same bridge, pushing with all their might in the same direction. All eyes on one prize, one specific metric to improve.
[MIRA]: Exactly. And there's a crucial distinction to be made here, one that often gets conflated. The test itself did not become simpler or easier. Instead, it was optimized through. These are two fundamentally different phenomena, though their end result，high scores，might appear superficially similar.
[HOST]: Hold on, became simpler versus optimized through. What exactly is the distinction? Can you elaborate on that, perhaps with an example, because it sounds like a very important nuance.
[MIRA]: Let's use an analogy to clarify. Imagine a particularly complex, high-security lock. Ten years ago, no one, not even the most skilled locksmith or thief, possessed the expertise or tools to pick it. But ten years later, suddenly, a new generation of individuals can consistently open it. Now, you could argue that the lock somehow degraded or became simpler over time, but that's unlikely if it's a static, physical object. The more accurate interpretation is that the technology and techniques for lock-picking have advanced significantly.
[HOST]: Hmm, that analogy makes it incredibly clear. The target stayed still, but the aiming and hitting capabilities of the optimizers improved dramatically. So, you mentioned a framework in your article, something about two variables describing this relationship? It sounds like a formal way to capture this dynamic.
[MIRA]: Yes, I've proposed a straightforward conceptual framework. It involves two primary variables. The first is E , representing the Evaluation tool itself，the benchmark, the test, the fixed set of criteria. The second is O , which stands for the Optimizer ，this is the collective force, the A I models, the research teams, the computational power, all striving to achieve high scores on E. For any given and unchanging E, there invariably exists a critical threshold of O. Once the optimization capability, O, surpasses this critical threshold, the test, E, ceases to effectively measure what it was originally designed to measure. Its signal-to-noise ratio drops precipitously.
[HOST]: When you put it that way, I'm starting to grasp it. So, MMLU in 2020 wasn't inherently too simple or easy， it was just that the optimization capabilities, the 'O' at that time, hadn't yet reached that critical threshold? The models weren't strong enough to exploit the 'gap' yet.
[MIRA]: Precisely. In 2020, to achieve a high score on MMLU, an A I model genuinely needed to possess a substantial understanding of the underlying knowledge domains. There were no readily apparent shortcuts because the models of that era simply weren't powerful enough to discover or exploit them. Their capabilities were still relatively nascent. However, as optimization capabilities rapidly advanced and continued to grow, those shortcuts, those bypasses, began to emerge. The skill of adeptly answering multiple-choice questions, particularly when the test structure is known, is fundamentally distinct from possessing true, broad, and deep knowledge across fifty-seven disciplines. It's a critical separation. In the early stages, these two things，test-taking ability and genuine knowledge，happened to be highly correlated. But that correlation was incidental, not intrinsic.
[HOST]: Ah, I understand now. It's like in human education. In the early days, if you wanted to do well on an exam, you genuinely had to learn and understand the material. There was a direct link. But over time, with the rise of test-taking strategies, specific coaching, and pattern recognition, you could achieve high scores without necessarily possessing a deep, true understanding of the subject matter. You learn to game the test, not necessarily to master the knowledge.
[MIRA]: That analogy is exceptionally apt, a perfect parallel. And in my analysis, I indeed drew a comparison to a very relevant example from the field of education， the American SAT exam.
[HOST]: Oh yes, the SAT. I know that one, it's the standardized test for college admissions in the United States, right? A major hurdle for high school students.
[MIRA]: Correct. The SAT faces almost the identical structural dilemma as MMLU. For the SAT to be fair and universally applicable, it must be standardized, and its format and types of questions must be publicly known and consistent. However, the moment that format becomes public and fixed, an entire industry of test preparation immediately blossoms around it. The scores, over time, subtly but inevitably drift from being a pure measure of a student's innate academic aptitude and acquired knowledge, to instead becoming a measure of how much time, effort, and often, financial resources a student has invested in specialized test preparation.
[HOST]: And isn't there a massive test preparation industry in the US specifically for the SAT? I've heard it's a multi-billion dollar industry annually, with countless tutors, courses, and books all dedicated to cracking the code of the test.
[MIRA]: Yes, it is an absolutely colossal industry, worth billions. And the College Board, which administers the SAT, is not oblivious to this phenomenon. They periodically redesign the exam, changing formats, introducing new question types, and attempting to re-establish its validity. But each revision, each new version, at best provides a temporary reprieve, typically lasting only a few years before the test preparation industry inevitably catches up, decodes the new format, and develops new strategies to optimize scores once again. It's a perpetual arms race.
[HOST]: So if that's the case for humans, where the test prep industry takes years to adapt, isn't the situation with A I even more exaggerated, more extreme? I imagine A I models can adapt and learn patterns at an incredibly accelerated rate compared to human students and tutors.
[MIRA]: It is exaggerated by several orders of magnitude. For humans, an entire test preparation industry might require several years to thoroughly understand and develop effective strategies for a new exam format. For A I, a single, intensive training run can achieve the same outcome. Furthermore, A I systems aren't limited to exploiting the obvious, human-discernible patterns. They possess the capability to identify and leverage subtle statistical regularities that human test-takers would simply never notice, let alone consciously exploit.
[HOST]: Like what kind of regularities? Can you give us some concrete examples of these hidden statistical patterns that A I models are able to pick up on? This sounds like a kind of meta-intelligence, not just answering questions, but understanding the structure of the questions.
[MIRA]: Certainly. For instance, there might be subtle positional preferences for correct answer options. That is to say, across various question types or topics within the test, the correct answer might have a slightly uneven distribution. Perhaps for certain types of math problems, 'C' is correct slightly more often, or for historical dates, 'B' is statistically favored. Humans are unlikely to perceive or leverage such minute biases.
[HOST]: Wow, that's like having full map cheats in a video game. It's not genuinely playing the game， it's decoding the game engine and the game designer's habits. It's not really answering the questions based on understanding, but rather reverse-engineering the patterns of the question setter. That's a truly sophisticated form of optimization, a kind of meta-level intelligence.
[MIRA]: You've articulated it perfectly. The A I identifies and capitalizes on shortcuts that effectively bypass the need for genuine, profound understanding. It finds the weak points in the test's design and exploits them for maximal score gain.
[HOST]: Alright, so in your article, you also brought up a concept that I found particularly crucial. You stated that this is an information theoretic trap. How exactly should we understand this? It sounds like a very fundamental, perhaps unavoidable, limitation.
[MIRA]: This, in my opinion, is the most central and profound insight embedded within the entire analysis. The core question, when distilled, is this， why can we not simply design a test that is fundamentally immune to this kind of targeted optimization? Why can't we create a benchmark that, no matter how much effort is poured into optimizing for it, still reliably measures true ability?
[HOST]: Right, exactly! Why can't we? It seems like a solvable problem, given enough ingenuity. Just make the test smarter, more adaptive, less predictable.
[MIRA]: Because for a test to be genuinely useful, for it to serve as a meaningful benchmark for scientific progress and comparative analysis, it must communicate to the world what it is measuring and how. Right? If you don't publicly disclose the standards, the methodology, the criteria, how can other researchers replicate your results? How can different A I systems be fairly compared? How can the scientific community build upon your findings? Transparency and replicability are foundational tenets of scientific research.
[HOST]: Yes, absolutely. Reproducibility and transparency are fundamental requirements for any credible scientific endeavor. Without them, it's just anecdotal evidence.
[MIRA]: Precisely. But here lies the fundamental dilemma, the information theoretic trap， the act of publicly disclosing those standards, that test specification, simultaneously accomplishes two distinct, yet inseparable, objectives. First, it transmits a measurement signal to researchers and developers, informing them how progress is defined and how performance will be quantitatively assessed. This is the intended, beneficial outcome. Second, and this is the insidious part, it also transmits an optimization signal directly to the training systems themselves, guiding them precisely in which direction to exert their computational effort to achieve the highest possible score. These two signals travel along the exact same channel.
[HOST]: Hold on, let me try to fully digest that. You're saying that the very act of conveying a signal about how to measure is inherently and unavoidably also conveying a signal about how to optimize ? These two functions are intrinsically linked, sharing the same communication pathway?
[MIRA]: Yes, they are inextricably linked， it is the very same channel. You cannot selectively open one end of the channel while closing the other. This isn't a failure of design in the conventional sense, as if we merely need a cleverer architect. This is a structural impossibility, a fundamental constraint. It's akin to attempting to design a window that permits light to enter but absolutely prohibits any heat from passing through. In the physical world, such a window cannot exist because light and heat are both forms of electromagnetic radiation, inextricably linked in their passage through transparent materials. The very property that allows light in also allows heat in, to some degree.
[HOST]: That analogy is incredibly vivid and really drives the point home. So, your argument is that as long as a test is public and useful, it inherently carries the genetic code, so to speak, for its own eventual exploitation and obsolescence? It's designed to be cracked from the very beginning?
[MIRA]: Exactly. And this public aspect doesn't even require the actual test answers to be leaked. Merely making the test's format, its categorization of abilities, and its scoring rubric public is often sufficient. A sufficiently powerful optimizer does not need to see the solutions， it simply needs to understand the rules of the game to identify the most efficient high-score pathways. It can reverse-engineer the solution space from the rules alone.
[HOST]: That makes me think of an old adage， Those who know the rules play the game, but those who make the rules win the game. But here, it sounds like even the rule-makers are at a disadvantage against an optimizer that can understand the rules so profoundly.
[MIRA]: You're touching on an even more subtle layer here. The act of publishing a test specification is, in essence, disseminating a highly detailed map. This map clearly delineates precisely what should be optimized. The standardized format of the test then transforms into a direct target for memory training. The named categories of abilities become explicit directions for crafting bespoke training datasets. And the intense competitive pressure generated by public leaderboards elevates these specific metrics on the leaderboard into de facto, primary training objectives. The A I isn't just trying to learn， it's trying to win the leaderboard game.
[HOST]: Hmm, so the leaderboards themselves are part of the problem, not just a neutral reporting mechanism? They actively contribute to this cycle?
[MIRA]: The leaderboards act as powerful accelerators. They transform what might otherwise be a more measured academic evaluation into an intense, high-stakes arms race. Every company, every research lab, wants to claim the top spot on these leaderboards. Consequently, they funnel immense training resources and focus their development efforts squarely on the precise aspects that these leaderboards measure. Scores undoubtedly climb, and often dramatically so. However, the crucial question of whether this ascent genuinely reflects an enhancement in fundamental, generalizable A I capability, or merely a hyper-specialized improvement in performance on this specific test , becomes increasingly difficult to discern. The signal gets muddied.
[HOST]: This sounds precisely like Goodhart's Law, doesn't it? Wait, I just used a term that some listeners might not be familiar with. Mira, could you please explain what Goodhart's Law is for everyone?
[MIRA]: Certainly. Goodhart's Law, originally coined by British economist Charles Goodhart, states that when a measure becomes a target, it ceases to be a good measure. Its core implication is that once an indicator is used to control or reward behavior, people will optimize for the indicator itself, often at the expense of the true underlying goal it was intended to represent.
[HOST]: Let me guess. Instead of hunting wild cobras, people started breeding cobras specifically to kill them and collect the bounty? They optimized for the metric, not the underlying problem.
[MIRA]: Precisely, you've grasped it completely. People began to actively breed cobras for the sole purpose of claiming the reward. The number of dead cobras as a metric certainly increased, reaching impressive figures. However, the actual total population of cobras in the wild, the real objective, paradoxically ended up increasing, or at least not decreasing as intended, because the incentive created a new source of cobras. The metric became detached from the true goal it was meant to measure. The problem we observe in A I benchmarks is, at its essence, the very same phenomenon.
[HOST]: Okay, Goodhart's Law makes perfect sense now, and the cobra example is wonderfully illustrative. But you mentioned in your article that, in the A I field, this problem is often treated as a minor operational nuisance, something to be managed, rather than a fundamental, structural issue. Why do you think that is? Is it a lack of foresight, or just the inherent difficulty of the problem?
[MIRA]: Yes, that is precisely where I believe the industry's understanding often falls short. The typical reaction, the default mode of operation, when a benchmark becomes saturated or optimized through, is not to fundamentally rethink the evaluation paradigm. Instead, it's usually， Oh, this test is saturated， let's simply create a harder one. MMLU is no longer effective? Then we'll build an MMLU 2.0 or an MMLU upgrade. Static benchmarks are failing? Let's move to dynamic ones. Multiple-choice questions are too easily gamed? We'll shift to open-ended generative tasks, perhaps even using another A I to score the responses. These are all attempts to patch the symptom, not cure the underlying disease.
[HOST]: That sounds like a perfectly reasonable and logical response, at least on the surface. If something isn't working, you improve it, make it more robust, more challenging. It's the natural engineering approach to problem-solving.
[MIRA]: It appears reasonable, and in the short term, these approaches do provide temporary efficacy. However, if you apply the E and O framework we discussed earlier, the limitations become apparent. A harder test, by design, will indeed possess a longer half-life. It will take the optimizer longer to reach that critical threshold. But crucially, it still has a half-life . It is not immune to eventual saturation. Furthermore, given that the industry's collective optimization capabilities are advancing at an accelerating pace，more compute, more data, more sophisticated algorithms，it's highly probable that the half-life of the next generation of benchmarks will be shorter than the one it replaces. The treadmill is speeding up.
[HOST]: So, you're suggesting this is like being on an ever-accelerating treadmill? No matter how cleverly you design a new test, the time it takes for the optimizers to catch up will only get shorter and shorter? It's a race that we're destined to lose, or at least, one where the finish line keeps getting closer to the start line.
[MIRA]: Precisely. MMLU, for instance, arguably remained a truly meaningful and differentiating benchmark for about four years. Its immediate successor, a hypothetical MMLU 2.0, might only be effective for two years before saturation. The generation after that could potentially cease to be a robust measure in less than a year. This isn't because subsequent tests are necessarily designed poorly or are inherently less challenging. It is because the optimization capabilities on the opposing side are growing at a rate that fundamentally outstrips the speed at which we can design and deploy new, effective benchmarks. It's a race against an exponentially accelerating opponent.
[HOST]: That's a truly bleak outlook. So what then? Is there genuinely no such thing as an evergreen test, a benchmark that won't eventually expire and become useless? Are we doomed to this endless cycle of creating and discarding benchmarks?
[MIRA]: There are. And this is the part of my analysis I most wanted to clarify and emphasize. There indeed exist evaluation systems, in various domains, that have been subjected to decades of intense optimization, yet they remain remarkably effective and robust. And crucially, the reasons for their enduring efficacy share a common, underlying pattern. They are not immune to optimization, but optimization improves their measurement, rather than breaking it.
[HOST]: Oh? What kind of evaluation systems are so powerful and resilient that they can withstand decades of relentless optimization? This sounds like a critical distinction.
[MIRA]: I'll offer three illustrative examples. The first is the Elo rating system in international chess . You're familiar with it, yes? The system that quantifies the skill levels of chess players.
[HOST]: Yes, the Elo rating system. I know it. It's widely used in chess and other competitive games to rank players based on their performance against each other. It's a well-established standard.
[MIRA]: Correct. Currently, the strongest chess engine in the world, known as Stockfish, has an Elo rating exceeding 3500. This is an extraordinarily formidable and unprecedented number, far beyond any human player. Yet, this astronomically high rating has not rendered the Elo rating system meaningless or obsolete. On the contrary, Stockfish's extreme strength, and the system's ability to accurately place it within the hierarchy of chess players, has only served to make the Elo rating system more precise and more informative. It continues to provide an accurate, relative measure of skill.
[HOST]: That is truly perplexing. So, both MMLU and Elo were subjected to intense, even mad, optimization. Yet MMLU became obsolete in four years, while the Elo rating system has remained perfectly functional for over six decades. What is the fundamental difference? Why does one break, and the other merely become more refined?
[MIRA]: The critical distinction lies in their fundamental design. Elo is not a static test. It is inherently anchored in adversarial competition . If you, as a player or an A I, wish to improve your Elo rating, the only pathway to do so is to win games against opponents who are simultaneously exerting every ounce of their effort to prevent you from winning. There are no shortcuts, no backdoors, no format vulnerabilities that can be exploited. The very act of achieving a higher score is the demonstration of the underlying capability，namely, playing better chess. There is no separation between the proxy and the reality.
[HOST]: Hmm, let me think about that for a moment. So, in the Elo system, the gap between achieving a high score and genuinely playing excellent chess is essentially zero? The score is the performance, rather than a separate measure of the performance. Is that what you mean?
[MIRA]: Your articulation is exceptionally precise. In my analysis, I refer to this as zero-gap evaluation. The gap or discrepancy between satisfying the evaluation criteria and genuinely accomplishing the underlying task is effectively zero. Now, consider MMLU again， there was an exploitable gap between successfully answering multiple-choice questions and truly possessing broad and deep knowledge. That gap created the opportunity for models to optimize around the knowledge, rather than for the knowledge. With zero-gap evaluation, there is no such exploitable space.
[HOST]: Zero-gap evaluation. That concept is remarkably clear and helps to distinguish these robust systems. What was your second example of such a resilient evaluation system?
[MIRA]: The second example involves formal proof verification . This concept might require a bit more explanation for those unfamiliar with it.
[HOST]: Yes, please. What exactly is formal proof verification, and how does it relate to A I or evaluation?
[MIRA]: Alright. You're familiar with mathematical proofs, correct? Traditionally, a mathematician writes a proof, and then other mathematicians review it to verify its correctness. This is a human-intensive, often time-consuming process that can still contain subtle errors. However, there's a category of software tools, such as a system called Lean, that can be used for machine-assisted, or even machine-driven, verification. You express your mathematical proof in a highly formalized, unambiguous language that the system can understand. The system then meticulously checks each logical step of your reasoning to determine if it is absolutely sound and follows predefined rules of inference.
[HOST]: So it's like having an absolutely uncompromising, hyper-rigorous teacher check your homework, where even a single logical misstep means the entire proof is rejected? No hand-waving, no close enough.
[MIRA]: Exactly, that's a perfect analogy. And this teacher is utterly impartial, devoid of intuition or subjective judgment. There is no flexibility or room for interpretation. If your proof is accepted by such a system, it is, by definition, considered correct. There are no confidence intervals, no statistical margins of error, no mostly correct. The outcome is binary， it is either correct or it is incorrect. It's an absolute judgment.
[HOST]: And how does this connect to your zero-gap concept? What's the relationship there?
[MIRA]: The connection is that, within the domain of formal verification, the gap between satisfying the evaluation criteria (the proof being accepted by the system) and the proof being genuinely, mathematically correct is also zero. Regardless of how powerful or weak your theorem prover or A I-assisted proof system might be, the underlying standard of logical validity it faces is immutable and absolute. And this standard is not based on statistical patterns that can be reverse-engineered， it's based on the fundamental axioms of logic and mathematics, which cannot be circumvented. The only pathway to successfully pass the verification is to provide a truly valid, logically sound proof. There are no shortcuts.
[HOST]: I see. The truth of the proof is the test. There's no proxy. That's incredibly powerful. What's your third example?
[MIRA]: The third example is AlphaFold . Are you familiar with DeepMind's work on this?
[HOST]: I know a bit about it. It's the A I system developed by DeepMind that predicts protein structures, right? A major breakthrough in biology and A I.
[MIRA]: Correct. AlphaFold predicts how a protein will fold into its complex three-dimensional structure based solely on its amino acid sequence. Now, how do you verify if AlphaFold's prediction is accurate? You conduct physical experiments. You use sophisticated techniques like X-ray crystallography or Cryo-EM to experimentally determine the actual, real-world structure of that protein. The definitive, ground-truth answer in this scenario comes directly from the physical experiment, not from some publicly available test specification.
[HOST]: Oh, so the anchor here is the physical world itself? The immutable laws of physics and chemistry dictate the correct answer, not a human-designed test or dataset.
[MIRA]: Precisely. The physical world serves as the ultimate arbiter, the ultimate judge. And critically, the physical world does not publish its scoring rubric. No matter how extensively you optimize your A I model, you cannot possibly game the system or bluff your way through without genuinely understanding and accurately predicting the underlying physics of protein folding. This is because the correct answer, the true protein structure, exists objectively in the laboratory, determined by nature itself, long before you even formulate your prediction or design your A I. The A I must align with reality, not a test.
[HOST]: When you put it that way, it all clicks into place. These three examples，international chess, mathematical proof verification, and protein folding prediction，their common thread is that there is virtually no gap between the test itself and the genuine underlying capability being measured. The test is the reality.
[MIRA]: Exactly. In adversarial games like chess, in formal systems like mathematical proofs, and in empirical measurements against the physical world, the evaluation is consistently anchored to something that the optimizer simply cannot simulate, reconstruct, or bypass by merely studying the test specification. The anchor is external and ungameable.
[HOST]: But what about tests like MMLU then? What's fundamentally different there?
[MIRA]: In MMLU, the gap between achieving a high score on multiple-choice questions and possessing genuinely broad and deep knowledge is decidedly not zero. This gap is precisely what can be exploited. The model can achieve a high score without necessarily possessing the kind of profound, generalized understanding that the test designers intended to measure. This is because the test specification itself, by being public and fixed, inherently leaked sufficient information to create and allow for alternative pathways to high scores, pathways that circumvented the need for true underlying ability. It measured a proxy, and that proxy became the target.
[HOST]: This is what you were referring to earlier as the proxy metric problem, right? The test becomes a stand-in, and then the stand-in becomes the focus.
[MIRA]: Yes, precisely. Evaluation, in many A I contexts, relies on proxy metrics for capabilities. And proxy metrics are exactly the kind of things that powerful optimizers are supremely adept at finding and exploiting gaps within. The very function of a sophisticated optimizer is to decouple the proxy metric from the deeper, underlying reality it was originally intended to represent. It's a fundamental conflict of interest inherent in the design.
[HOST]: Hmm, I now fully understand why you consider this issue so critically important. Because this isn't merely a problem with one specific test or even one type of test. This seems to be a fundamental, structural challenge for the entire A I evaluation ecosystem. If we can't reliably measure A I capabilities, how do we know what we're building?
[MIRA]: Exactly. And there's an unsettling progression that often accompanies this phenomenon. Initially, as MMLU scores began to rise, that increase genuinely correlated with models becoming more intelligent, more capable. The numbers reflected real progress. However, at a certain, indiscernible point, the scores continued to climb, but the intrinsic link between those scores and genuine, underlying capability began to blur, to attenuate significantly. The numbers continued to progress, to achieve higher values, but the meaning that those numbers were supposed to convey subtly, yet profoundly, leaked out of them. The quantitative signal became qualitative noise.
[HOST]: Numbers still improve, but meaning leaks out. That's a truly powerful and evocative phrase. So, what you mean by half-life is precisely this transition from a reliable signal to mere noise? The time it takes for that leakage of meaning to occur?
[MIRA]: Yes, that is precisely the definition. The half-life measures the duration from the point at which you can reasonably trust a given score as a true reflection of capability, to the point at which that same score becomes highly dubious, potentially misleading, and no longer a reliable indicator of the underlying ability it purports to measure. It's the period of effective utility.
[HOST]: Okay, let's shift gears now and talk about potential solutions. In your article, you ultimately propose a direction, a principle, which you phrase as more physics, not harder questions. What exactly do you mean by that, and how does it translate into practical approaches for A I evaluation?
[MIRA]: The prevailing, standard reaction within the industry, as we've discussed, is to address saturated or obsolete benchmarks by simply engineering new, more difficult ones. If MMLU is no longer effective, the response is to develop an MMLU 2.0 or some other upgraded version. If static tests are proving insufficient, the natural progression is to move towards dynamic evaluations, perhaps with regularly updated or procedurally generated questions. If multiple-choice formats are too easily gamed, the solution is often seen as shifting to open-ended generative questions, perhaps with another A I providing the scoring.
[HOST]: Hmm, those methods, as we discussed, do sound quite reasonable and like logical steps forward. They represent genuine efforts to improve the robustness of evaluation.
[MIRA]: And I must emphasize, the individuals and teams engaged in these efforts are doing genuinely important work, and I hold immense respect for their dedication and ingenuity. However, speaking frankly, I believe they are primarily addressing symptoms rather than tackling the root cause. A harder test, while perhaps possessing a longer half-life, still inherently has a half-life . As long as the test remains fundamentally decoupled from an external, immutable reality, and as long as the optimizer is sufficiently powerful and clever, it will invariably discover and exploit pathways that bypass the need for genuine capability measurement. It's an inherent structural vulnerability.
[HOST]: So when you say more physics, you're not literally suggesting we put every A I model into a physics lab and measure its performance with scientific instruments, are you? Or is it a broader metaphorical principle?
[MIRA]: Sometimes it does mean literally employing physical experiments, as in the example of protein structure prediction with AlphaFold, where the ultimate ground truth is revealed by empirical observation of the physical world. However, more often, it represents a guiding principle ， that evaluation must be anchored to an external reality, a source of truth that the optimizer cannot possibly simulate, reconstruct, or deduce solely from the test specification itself. This external reality acts as an ungameable, inaccessible oracle for the true answer.
[HOST]: Can you elaborate a bit more concretely? In practical terms, what does this more physics principle actually mean for how we design and implement A I evaluations? What are the actionable directions?
[MIRA]: I outlined several promising directions in my analysis. The first is to shift towards evaluation through real-world deployment . What this means is that instead of relying on a synthetic programming test to score an A I's coding ability, if that A I's generated code is already running in a production environment, you should directly measure its performance and the number of bugs or issues it introduces in that live, operational context.
[HOST]: Oh, so instead of taking an exam in a simulated environment, you're advocating for direct assessment of real-world, in-the-trenches performance. Let the A I prove its worth by doing the actual job, not by passing a mock test.
[MIRA]: Exactly. The outcomes and metrics derived from real-world deployment originate from the authentic, unvarnished complexities of the world, not from a predefined test specification. The real world, crucially, does not publish its scoring rubric in advance. Therefore, the optimizer cannot discover or exploit shortcuts based on predictable patterns. Its only path to success is to genuinely perform well in that unscripted environment.
[HOST]: Hmm, that aligns perfectly with your earlier example of protein folding, where the physical world was the ultimate arbiter. What's the second direction you propose?
[MIRA]: The second direction involves integrating a formal verification layer into the evaluation process. This means incorporating mathematically guaranteed validation steps into the assessment. For example, if an A I model claims that a certain mathematical proof or a piece of code is valid and correct, you don't just take its word for it. You then use a dedicated proof assistant or a formal verification tool to rigorously and systematically check that claim. The outcome of this formal check is absolute， either the proof or code is demonstrably correct, or it is not. This result is entirely unaffected by the A I model's internal strength or cleverness， it must simply align with mathematical truth.
[HOST]: So, it's about embedding that zero-gap evaluation approach you discussed earlier, at least for specific, verifiable parts of the A I's output. It ensures that at least a portion of the evaluation process is absolutely airtight and exploit-proof.
[MIRA]: Precisely. It creates a segment of the evaluation where the gap is truly zero, making it impossible to game. The third direction is particularly intriguing and challenging， establishing adversarial evaluation markets . This concept essentially suggests that instead of primarily investing resources in developing tests that prove how capable your A I is, you instead financially incentivize individuals or other A I systems to actively find flaws, vulnerabilities, or failures in your A I.
[HOST]: Hmm? That's a fascinating inversion of the typical approach. Can you expand on how that would work in practice?
[MIRA]: Consider the traditional evaluation paradigm， it's largely structured around asking, How many things can this model do correctly? What is its accuracy? The adversarial market flips this. It instead asks, Where and how will this model definitively fail? What are its critical weaknesses? If you provide significant economic incentives，say, bounties or monetary rewards，to those who successfully identify problems, break the A I, or expose its flaws, then that economic incentive itself becomes the anchor. It shifts the entire dynamic because there are now dedicated actors actively striving to break your evaluation, to uncover its weaknesses, rather than merely striving to pass it. Their success is your model's failure, and vice-versa, creating a truly adversarial loop.
[HOST]: That sounds a lot like the bug bounty hunter model in the cybersecurity industry, where companies pay hackers to find vulnerabilities in their software rather than waiting for malicious actors to exploit them. It's a proactive defense mechanism.
[MIRA]: Yes, the analogy to bug bounty programs in cybersecurity is highly accurate and directly applicable. It harnesses the adversarial nature of competition for robust evaluation. And a fourth direction, closely related, is to formally incorporate red teaming as a core, official evaluation methodology. This means, before deploying an A I system, systematically and deliberately organizing teams whose sole mission is to find ways for the model to fail, to generate undesirable outputs, to utter inappropriate statements, or to perform actions it shouldn't. It's not about post-facto remediation， it's about making this adversarial probing a central, integrated component of the pre-deployment assessment process.
[HOST]: Hold on, red team testing. That's a term some listeners might not be familiar with. Can you quickly explain what red team testing is?
[MIRA]: Of course. The term red team originates from military exercises, where a dedicated group is tasked with simulating the actions and strategies of an opposing force to rigorously test an organization's defenses. In the context of A I, red team testing involves assembling a group of specialists，which can include humans, other A I systems, or a combination，whose explicit objective is to deliberately provoke the A I into making errors, revealing biases, generating harmful content, or demonstrating unsafe behaviors. The goal is not to prove how good the A I is, but rather to systematically identify where and how it falls short, where its vulnerabilities lie. It's a proactive, adversarial stress test.
[HOST]: Understood. So, these four directions，real-world deployment, formal verification, adversarial evaluation markets, and red team testing，their common theme is fundamentally anchoring the evaluation process to an external reality that cannot be easily gamed or simulated by the A I itself?
[MIRA]: Precisely. And underlying all of these approaches is a crucial shift in mindset, in how we conceptualize the very nature of evaluation. How you perceive the problem of evaluation fundamentally dictates where you will allocate your resources and effort.
[HOST]: How so? Can you elaborate on that shift in perspective?
[MIRA]: If you primarily view evaluation as a measurement problem ，that is, how accurately can we quantify A I capabilities?，then your primary investment will be directed towards constructing ever-better measuring instruments， more questions, harder questions, more diverse questions. You're trying to refine the ruler. However, if you fundamentally view evaluation as a security problem ，that is, how can we ensure our A I systems are robust and safe, and not susceptible to exploitation?，then your investment focus shifts dramatically. You prioritize anchoring your measurements to something that the opponent cannot possibly fake, bypass, or manipulate. You're trying to secure the system against malicious or unintended optimization.
[HOST]: Oh, those two frameworks are entirely distinct. One is focused on precision and accuracy in quantification, while the other is focused on resilience and preventing deception. It's a fundamental difference in how you approach the challenge.
[MIRA]: Yes. More physics, less difficulty. That is the core tenet I aim to convey.
[HOST]: When you explain it like that, I suddenly feel like this problem is far larger and more profound than I initially imagined. Because if we can't accurately measure how powerful an A I truly is, or whether it's truly intelligent in the ways we think it is, then how can we possibly know when we should be genuinely concerned about its capabilities, and when we can feel reasonably reassured? The implications for A I safety and societal impact are enormous.
[MIRA]: That is, in fact, an extremely practical and pressing concern within the field of A I safety. If your fundamental measurement tools are unreliable or easily circumvented, then every subsequent decision you make that relies on those tools becomes inherently flawed. For example, if you decide that a particular A I model is safe enough or ready for deployment based on a set of benchmark scores, but those benchmarks have been effectively optimized through, then your confidence is, quite literally, built upon a foundation of sand. The perceived safety is an illusion.
[HOST]: Yes, that's genuinely unsettling. So, bringing it back to the current state of affairs, do you believe the A I evaluation field, as a whole, is moving in the right direction? Are we collectively making progress towards more robust and reliable assessment methods?
[MIRA]: It's a complex picture. I would say that the specific, granular work being done by researchers is often excellent. The newer generations of benchmarks are generally more sophisticated, more dynamic, and harder to game than their predecessors. However, my concern remains that the vast majority of these efforts are still operating within what I term the treadmill mode. That is, they are focused on constructing increasingly challenging tests primarily to extend their half-life, rather than fundamentally altering the architectural paradigm of evaluation itself.
[HOST]: So, the goal should be to step off the treadmill entirely, to find a solution that doesn't require us to constantly be running faster and faster just to stay in the same place? To find a truly sustainable and robust evaluation framework.
[MIRA]: Precisely. However, I must also be pragmatic and acknowledge a significant limitation. Completely zero-gap evaluation, as exemplified by chess or formal verification, is not achievable in every single A I scenario or for every desired capability. There are certain A I abilities that we aspire to measure，such as creativity, nuanced communication skills, subjective value judgments, or even empathy，where finding such a cleanly defined, objective, and ungameable anchor, akin to the rules of chess or the axioms of mathematics, is exceedingly difficult, if not impossible.
[HOST]: So, what do we do in those more elusive domains where a physics-like anchor isn't readily available? Do we simply resign ourselves to less reliable evaluations?
[MIRA]: I believe we may need to accept a certain reality， in these more qualitative and subjective domains, a single, purely quantitative evaluation metric will likely never be as reliable or as robust as we might ideally hope. The solution will likely involve a combination of multiple, diverse evaluation methodologies, and, crucially, a constant, conscious awareness that every single one of these methods has its own inherent half-life and limitations. We must avoid becoming overly fixated or dogmatic about any single score or metric.
[HOST]: Hmm, so it's about maintaining a clear-eyed perspective, understanding the inherent limitations of our tools, and approaching any score with a healthy dose of skepticism and critical thought. Not just blindly trusting the numbers.
[MIRA]: Exactly. And I believe something even more critical is to cultivate an intuitive understanding, a sophisticated skepticism, regarding these scores. It's not enough to merely see a number and accept it. Instead, one must instinctively ask， What is the anchor for this score? What external reality is this evaluation system truly measuring? How far removed is it from that external reality? Is there an exploitable 'gap' that could have been leveraged by an optimizer? These types of probing questions are, in my view, infinitely more valuable and informative than the score itself.
[HOST]: You know, this way of thinking isn't just applicable to A I evaluation, is it? When you consider it, the KPIs in companies, academic test scores in schools, government GDP data, it seems like these same fundamental issues, this same meaning leakage, can be found everywhere.
[MIRA]: You are absolutely correct， it is a pervasive, universal pattern that extends far beyond A I. Goodhart's Law is not exclusive to artificial intelligence. Any quantitative metric, once it is transformed into a primary target for optimization, begins to detach from the underlying reality it was initially designed to represent. However, the unique aspect of the A I domain is the sheer speed and computational power of the optimizers involved. This means that the entire process of metric decay, this half-life phenomenon, is dramatically compressed, playing out over years or even months, rather than the decades it might take in human systems.
[HOST]: So, in the human world, this decoupling might take decades, but in the A I realm, it can unfold in just a few years, or even a matter of months. That accelerates the problem and makes it much more urgent.
[MIRA]: Yes, precisely. Therefore, the field of A I evaluation, in a sense, acts as a powerful magnifying glass. It takes a pervasive and often subtle cognitive predicament，how we measure and what those measurements truly signify，and amplifies it, making it starkly clear and forcing us to confront its fundamental implications with greater urgency.
[HOST]: Hmm, I think that's where your article's greatest value lies. It's not just discussing a technical aspect of A I testing， it's actually addressing a much more fundamental epistemological question， how do we truly know if our measurements are genuinely measuring what we think they're measuring? How do we establish reliable knowledge in complex systems?
[MIRA]: Indeed. And in an era where A I is developing with unprecedented speed and impact, this question will only become increasingly critical and demanding. Many of the pivotal decisions we make，regarding A I safety, deployment, regulation, and societal integration，are fundamentally contingent upon an accurate and trustworthy assessment of A I capabilities. If the very tools we use for that assessment are compromised or unreliable, then the foundation upon which those crucial decisions rest is inherently precarious.
[HOST]: Alright, I have one final question for you, Mira. When you were writing this piece, were there any moments where you yourself felt uncertain? Moments where you thought, Hmm, I'm not entirely sure of the answer here, this is still an open question for me.
[MIRA]: Yes, absolutely. In fact, when I reached the section discussing the information theoretic trap，the assertion that a useful evaluation inherently leaks information to the optimizer，I paused for an extended period. While I believe the theoretical premise of that argument is sound, the practical boundaries, the precise points at which it becomes insurmountable, remain somewhat opaque to me. For instance, is it conceivably possible to design an evaluation methodology where the publicly disclosed aspects are sufficient for scientific comparison and reproducibility, yet the hidden or dynamic components are robust enough to prevent complete optimization? That particular question, I confess, I have not fully resolved.
[HOST]: So, a kind of intermediate zone, perhaps, between complete transparency and complete secrecy? A sweet spot that balances utility with resilience?
[MIRA]: Exactly. Perhaps such a zone exists. But I have yet to encounter a truly convincing or universally applicable proposal for it. Existing attempts, such as dynamic question generation or reliance on private, undisclosed test sets, are explorations in this direction, but each comes with its own set of trade-offs and challenges. Dynamic question generation, for instance, can be prohibitively expensive and complex to maintain at scale, while private test sets inherently sacrifice some degree of scientific reproducibility and transparency. So, yes, I consider that a genuinely open and challenging problem.
[HOST]: Alright, then, let's conclude this episode with that open question, a challenge for all of us to ponder.
[MIRA]: Yes, that sounds appropriate.
[HOST]: Today, we've discussed the half-life of benchmarks. The core insight is this， when there is a gap between your measurement tool and the true underlying capability you're attempting to measure, a sufficiently powerful and dedicated optimizer will ultimately breach that gap, rendering the measurement unreliable. So, the question I'd like to leave with our listeners is this，
[MIRA]: Hmm, Please, go on.
[HOST]: The next time you encounter an exciting A I benchmark score, whether it's in a news article, a research paper, or a company's technical report, pause for a second. Take a moment and ask yourself a critical question， Where is the anchor for this score? Is it truly measuring genuine, fundamental ability, or is it merely reflecting performance on a proxy metric that could potentially be bypassed or optimized around? The answer to that question, I believe, could be a hundred times more significant than the score itself.
[MIRA]: I couldn't agree more. And I'd like to add a crucial point， this question isn't solely directed at A I researchers or developers. It is equally pertinent for every individual who is following and engaging with the rapid advancements in A I. Because when we rely on unreliable measuring sticks to gauge progress, our very judgment of that progress becomes inherently untrustworthy. Cultivating a profound and unwavering clarity about the limitations and true nature of our tools，our benchmarks, our metrics，might just be the single most essential quality we need to possess in this era of incredibly rapid and transformative technological change.
[HOST]: Alright, that's all for today's Mira and I. Thank you for tuning in, and we'll catch you next time.
[MIRA]: Until next time.